hi what's up - sup bill burr hanging out
at the Comedy Store during the day
because I have no life and that guy just
asked me if my Prius was a Lexus I don't
know what he's listening to but I'm
going to download it the second I get
out there hi yeah I'm a huge [ __ ]
sports fan and all that LeBron [ __ ] that
was going on this week out of everything
that was annoying about that that
players were actually getting together
now to decide what team they're gonna
piggyback on the thing that bugged me
the most was all those New York fans all
the Knick fans when LeBron didn't pick
New York we're trying to say that the
guy was afraid of New York in the big
stage and I just wanted to address this
point because I have no [ __ ] life and
I actually have the time in the middle
of I've sold so what's so little going
on in my career that I can actually
address this in the middle of the
[ __ ] day
what big stage are you talking about
Knick fans what are you talking about
what Madison Square Garden you guys are
acting like like it's [ __ ] Yankee
Stadium you haven't won a championship
since like 1973 so what what is he
afraid of what pressure is there to
carry the [ __ ] torch to not win it
for the 38th 39th and 40th [ __ ] year
I just you know I would never as a Red
Sox fan act like Fenway Park is this big
stage in baseball knowing that the
Yankees are down the street with 20 more
[ __ ] championships the Celtics have
17 [ __ ] banners hanging from their
arena
all right so stand the [ __ ] down you
don't have a big stage you know what
Madison Square Garden you know it's a
big stage for [ __ ] like God
what's that chick who can't talk anymore
went on the road with Frank Liza
Minnelli it's a big stage for her when
she goes down there and she does her
Fosse [ __ ] hands in front of all
those Elton John fans that's it haven't
you ever noticed the [ __ ] draft when
you go to a Knicks game or a Rangers
game for that matter you know what that
is that's from all the open air from all
those lack of championship banners up
there all right
the [ __ ] Minneapolis Lakers
who disbanded in like the early 60s have
three more [ __ ] championships than
you okay I'm not trying to be a [ __ ]
here even though I am you guys don't
have a big stage there yeah little
[ __ ] stage a little [ __ ] let's go
do some summer stock maybe do a little
bit of Shakespeare all right the big
[ __ ] stage walk because you got to
look around Tyra Banks we've that that
makes it a big [ __ ] stage [ __ ]
who's that little [ __ ] with the with the
bloody Holly glasses
Spike Lee spending his towels the last
guy in Madison Square Gardens Jersey
brought up to the rafters was [ __ ]
Reggie Miller alright LeBron was not
afraid to go there there's no winning
tradition in New York City was he afraid
of [ __ ] film mushnick and his [ __ ]
man tits and his laptop is good old
LeBron isn't getting it done nobody
gives a [ __ ] so much dick is never in a
good mood he makes me look like a happy
guy and you [ __ ] [ __ ] a sitting
there giving LeBron [ __ ] that if he goes
to the Miami Heat
that if he wins down there it's Dwyane
Wade's team so you know no one's going
to respect
LeBron if he wins down there well then
what the [ __ ] of the Yankees last 12
years
everybody from [ __ ] Kevin Brown to
a-rod have piled on that team you guys
invented that [ __ ] so put your [ __ ]
crying alright and get on your [ __ ]
knees and thank thank thank the [ __ ]
[ __ ] man run I'm stuttering because
it's day at a light out here know it's
bugging the [ __ ] out of me all right
I [ __ ] respect the Yankees you guys
are the epicenter a professional [ __ ]
baseball but don't [ __ ] try and act
like the [ __ ] Knicks are you're not
you're not the [ __ ] Spurs have more
flags than you have you ever been to San
Antonio you have it and I'm sick of
people acting like New York is a hard
[ __ ] place to live you can make it
there you can make it anywhere look at
your life look around your apartment
right now you're in New York right
you're making it you can get a [ __ ]
slice it's not that hard Frank Sinatra
was from New Jersey stop trying to claim
him - he was bridge-and-tunnel and he
came in and he took over your [ __ ]
town
and there he ate your pizza and he
[ __ ] your women and you did nothing
about it and now you play a song at the
end of the Yankees game all right
that's all I want to say is you don't
have a big stage in MSG until you get
into double digits with your [ __ ]
Flags first have a little bit of [ __ ]
respect that's like the twins talking
[ __ ] to the Yankees so what happened
you're [ __ ] conclusion you don't have
a big stage down there you don't all
right the Yankees are the big thing
other than that New York City is a
horrific failure in sports you'd double
down and half the [ __ ] major sports
you know Jets haven't wanted since 69
Knicks haven't won and since 73 the
[ __ ] Rangers upon one Cup in 70 years
where is this big States a [ __ ] Mets
haven't won it since 86 the Giants are a
respectable franchise but they're
respectable that's it they got three
Super Bowl rings you know else history
is the [ __ ] Patriots the Green Bay
Packers the [ __ ] Oakland Raiders
you're in the middle of the pack upper
echelon in football is [ __ ] Steelers
cowboys and 49ers then there's a moat
because nobody has four so you really
don't have a big [ __ ] stage there and
Ray's famous pizza isn't [ __ ] famous
so stop eating everything in New York is
to [ __ ] just because time squares up
there and you can jerk off in front of
the [ __ ] MTV building all right
that's it have a nice day New York and
I'm glad you didn't get Cliff Lee you
[ __ ] [ __ ]